what's up reject nation what's ups i'm a
cool youtuber
we're gonna watch umbrella academy
season two episode three today excited
to check this out make sure to subscribe
and click that notification bell so you
can get notified when our next umbrella
academy reaction is up or if there's
just another video of ours that sounds
interesting and you get
notified for this is going to be
reaction highlights because youtube
supposedly only allows 10 minutes worth
of footage should be shown on youtube
full length reaction watch alongs will
be available over at our patreon page
speaking of which thank you guys so much
to everyone who has shown their support
patreon over there we have a weekly q a
podcast we also do many tv show reaction
watch along as many of those shows have
highlights included as well and those
shows are here we go supernatural doctor
who jojo's bizarre adventure the proper
summerlin attack on titan death note my
hero academia code yes hunter hunter one
punch man full metal cause brotherhood
finally never gonna do and slayer many
of those shows have watch alongs only
go check us out today over there all
right let's do it
[Music]
sorry i became a guru you need to get
out i am a member of the royal family
[Laughter]
hello rich lady oh is he going to be a
chef oh yes
clever snake sugar baby klaus oh that's
how they got the house
what are we doing here what the [ __ ]
is he having been everything ghost
slipped him up what the hell
please show the ghost slipped [ __ ]
this is so great yeah you got some
strength before it goes
[Laughter]
oh ben is a crush
wow let's do it traveling damn you went
around
all russell brand yeah totally total
russell brand vibes
he's oh he's got too much fame
stop touching me
oh is ben's unfinished business with
that girl
boo that makes sense
there's no natural spot for an umbrella
let's just make the birds do it yeah
it's fine
oh they shaved he shaved him that's
that's the most important thing
not the bullet you had to clean them up
in space
i love getting lost in this show same
uh oh is this sweet
use your power finders next line's going
to be
i could go for some milk
run son so they're not here to save her
all things considered she drove off with
a pretty calm look on her face very true
this is gonna cause her powers to come
unleashed huh oh
come on vanya come on [ __ ] need some
corn for the house come on vanya
you guys are terrible hitmen you guys
are like stormtroopers dude
how can you miss her come on man i saw
what you guys were all doing back at the
house
you're no you're no hazel in cha-cha wow
what a shot
wow that was cool use your powers girl
hey
hell yeah did you guys not know she had
powers going into this
oh alice i didn't even notice that now
well she doesn't like that allison he
knows doesn't look like that
so what do you think it's her all right
carry on
carry on no
freaking way bro how oh we found oh
i see look you can either stay here and
wait for the ikea mafia to come back
damn son oh and it's just gonna look
more like alien sightings
with the crawfield
holy cow dang vania oh i thought she's
gonna make an umbrella
that's a perfect circle she could have a
great job working the field
you sure yeah i'm my number one guy
luther's gonna call him dad at one point
daddy is he going to be a racist
oh did she have classes how did she find
him what
oh because the guys last season yeah
oh what is the one grade five this way
[Laughter]
you definitely see the wig through his
hair
[Laughter]
yeah still use it though
[Laughter]
it really helped me in a piglet
[Laughter]
oh she's talking sternly
[Music]
we will continue to fight for equality
even in the face of persecution
with or without ray all in favor
oh yeah you're not with the cause
yeah how is this gonna go and like oh
there's people looking at each other
like
ray's not here
can't eat that tarnish
i think ben is breaking raymond out
yeah family brother
family barbecues are about to get really
[Laughter]
weird
[Laughter]
what causes the apocalypse you do girl i
don't know
what asteroid impact he cares i got the
dinosaurs
you're technically not lying you know i
feel like don't tell vanya right away
but you guys got to tell her the truth
before she remembers
of course she just snapped again
that's
wow that'll [ __ ] you up
[Music]
[Laughter]
i don't understand you
oh my god i wonder if older
older five is there too oh yeah because
he was sent back in time to kill jfk
yeah yeah we remember the first season
he found his woman i mean you'd think
that the guy would be like yo
she's married chestnut's going to answer
the door who are you whitey behind you
oh that's oh chestnut's coming he's
getting out of the car
just say you're his sister is her
sisters
who's white i guess we haven't been that
[Laughter]
close
[Music]
it's real sad and you can't [ __ ] your
sister they're not blood related i mean
yeah technically
[Laughter]
no matter what i say i look weird
it's not real incense
[Laughter]
this is hot country ooh the audacity
oh hell yeah
they've had to practice to be able to
get beat without
without reacting or without uh fighting
back
this is true scary just thinking how
raymond's probably having a trippiest
time like
met two different brothers right none
are black
[Music]
paint yeah i'm ben cut it out man
come on let him talk
oh poor klaus
poor guy maybe i can convince him not to
sign up for that stupid war maybe i can
save his life
selfless little selfish but selfless
just promise me you can handle this
whatever happens
i'm really noticing how like everyone
feels more like siblings this time
around as
family yeah [ __ ] other [ __ ]
racists i hate this
[Laughter]
don't touch me woman do you think she
was having an affair
is now the time to be doing it right
should we really be a disagreement dude
don't get distracted use that anger boy
why are you mother [ __ ] jesus
i hate this tell a tell a [ __ ] rumor
oh please don't kill raymond right now
please no
no no no not now no jesus christ
stop tell a [ __ ] rumor come on carol
rumor come on stop him
okay good
we knew it what are you wife
jesus christ
i don't think this is the proper
reaction someone will be having right
now
that's a hell of a hit damn it's like
how the movie snatch
because he's sad
oh poor guy
you got me in the heart man what
oh she with is she with that the bureau
or the agency or whatever
no oh she definitely knows about this
she know yeah she knows
she knows all about this oh is she with
the [ __ ] she has to be
uh no got trapped
[Music]
no
[Music]
what game was she playing she like major
undercover
mom what
what what is this game they're playing
hell no dude what a cliffhanger
wow if only we could just watch the next
episode
[Laughter]
darn we have to wait so long
let's talk about it holy [ __ ] [ __ ]
and cheese oh man
it's funny because like the literally
the last episode i was like i don't know
i don't know how i feel about lily yeah
what's her deal and i was like but i
know this show they always
a lot of times i'm like i don't know how
i feel about them then eventually the
show's like oh they got me
yeah and there's not here for no reason
yeah and then
suddenly you get this this ending reveal
it just has your mind racing it's an
interesting thing
stopping and reviewing a netflix show
because i release all the episodes at
once
and i feel like in that binge watching
mentality
which i've done with other shows i did
with the first season of this that it
can be harder to appreciate the
individual episodes so i actually like
when we cover
netflix shows because all the episodes
are released instead of just binging it
he could really dissect and appreciate
each individual episode and this is a
case of that because i'm like it's cool
watching the trajectory of like you have
the first episode that's very exciting
yeah
grab your attention as the show has been
slowly going through the episodes
especially with this one you get a lot
more dark intensity and true emotional
feels
throughout the beginning of this episode
with vanya yes she unleashes her powers
the swedes are coming after her i like
how the swedes are just treated like
just
yeah just like terminators
there's no no witty banter between them
like season one yeah
all business because you you had uh
hazel and cha-cha
which were really unique characters to
be the hitmen from the bureau
then the bureau becomes reactionary and
we're like we just need the coldest
people we can find the coldest
swedish ikea i love that
get them in there and then with vania
and five reuniting i think it's cool how
five is very reliant on his family this
season around where
the first season he was someone who was
like i just need to do this on my own
and eventually he realized he needed to
do with his family and then this one is
like no we need to get
everyone together right now total flip
of this yeah i just find it really
endearing
vania has to find out the truth sooner
than later yeah she needs
like as a character she needs to she
yeah of course i feel like it's going to
take something tragic for her to realize
and come to terms
i have a feeling it's going to be the
seeing of allison that's going to kind
of trigger
that kind of memory with the scar
because the scar yeah exactly because
she's the one that [ __ ] did that and
this isn't a lot of ways
out of everyone's episode it felt like
this was allison's episode everything
kind of circled back to her
because you got like klaus and allison
luther allison raymond and allison
yeah and i really dig that because she
had lily and allison
speaking of the the klaus and allison
thing i really like that moment between
them because i don't really think they
had that in the first season i don't
think they really gave them a chance
time to shine well i feel like everyone
feels more like
family they feel like actual family and
siblings it doesn't feel
jarringly different it feels
appropriately different because they
were so distant in the first
episode of season one and they're coming
back together now when they you know
see each other if they recognize each
other the history of the love yeah
especially with klaus and allison like
yeah they're family the show keeps
telling me they're family and it's nice
when you see
the actual family dynamic and it even
goes to klaus and ben and the way they
interact with each other with the way
they fight with one another the way they
come to certain resolves with one
another
feels very brother-like where the
animosity feels authentic and then the
resolve and understanding feels
authentic as well right
you finally got to see why klaus wants
to go to dallas and why
ben wants to stay in san francisco even
though i thought it was funny and kind
of ironic that he called him out and
being a stalker but he's trying to stalk
this this girl in san francisco
i don't know yet though we don't know
you i don't know yet she could be a
medium club seems like he's drug free
when alison came to see him
she he said you know dicks drugs and all
that jazz so
he has been doing drugs they just
haven't really focused on that
but he doesn't look as much of an
emotional wreck yeah
he seems depressed but he doesn't seem
like he's out of control chaotic
i think he's come to terms with the
whole being able to
to see ghost thing and interact with him
yeah so i don't feel like he's using it
like a mechanism to kind of
to run away from it yeah i feel like
he's kind of learned how to
how to balance that drug use and balance
that
that which we all should do we should
all learn to balance that
do drugs moderate yes i mean it feels
very
human and i think that's like a a this
is one of the
biggest strengths of this show in
particular how human everyone feels
i really appreciate from a scripting
structuring standpoint how they were
cutting back and forth between
intense sequences of what we're going on
with the backdrop of the civil rights
movement
happening here because you're really
honing in on
what this year this era represents
and it's like yeah could they go a
little bit more hard-hitting with like
the
ultra realism they might go there more
the civil rights movement
anytime i see anything related to that
or documentaries or whatever i
i can't i tend to get very emotional
yeah
i was getting heated i was like yo this
is not cool like
i was telling myself like don't start
crying again because this is probably
gonna keep coming back in the show
you're still gonna be crying
i feel like we had opposite reactions i
feel like it was making you sad and
making me angry well maybe you would
make you angry just angry
a little bit different i i i i get
really emotional about it but the way
raymond's reacting
like i don't i don't buy it you don't
buy it you don't buy it
i also don't blame him though how can
you comprehend what's going on it's just
like that fast i can see from a
perspective
of i can't speak to it but from what the
show is communicating to me
a black husband who's doing is in the
civil rights movement
trying to be a leader of a certain group
this woman who you've only known for a
couple of years
right she couldn't even talk the first
year i guess we don't know exactly when
they
met so you got this white slash ethnic
dude bailing you out of jail
and then this tall white dude showed up
who looks all heartbroken
over the marriage looks like you're
sleeping around communicating to a white
cop
about letting you go it's like i can
just imagine the world of mystery i mean
in the moment i i guess when raymond was
re reacting
angrily or in a suspicious manner i
really bought it i didn't get why he
freaked out and ran um
i have an open mind just to let us know
why you were thinking maybe the show
will just elaborate more later on yeah
why he freaked out so much about what
did you say
oh my god because in that moment i would
have been like wait who are you exactly
yeah yeah i don't even think that i'd be
like grateful like
stop this cop from beating the [ __ ] out
of me i almost died you saved my life
what is the visual language of what can
he see
when they do the rumor does he see the
weird things that we're seeing like
without yeah or is he just seeing her
whispering and then
him walking away i don't think they did
this in the first season but the eyes
get all white when she tells the room
i don't think that happened did it i
don't know i don't believe so i don't
remember she didn't really do it that
much
everyone she does it too this season
goes all like full storm from x-men with
the white eyes so i wonder if he's
seeing that and she's like whoa
freaky my wife has powers it's just how
you got uh
diego who is the character they coined
as the one with the
hero complex right but in a lot of ways
they all do you know and i think that's
what's really interesting about their
characters they're all looking for a
purpose
to some degree like diego is actually
the most constant with like i just got
to be a hero
yeah klaus is trying to find like other
than being you know greedy and looking
out for himself now he's trying to save
david
of course that comes from the motivation
of his history with the vietnam war
and being lovers you got allison getting
involved in the civil rights movement
luther seems like he's trying to get
away from it all i'm really loving the
luther like it's funny because
luther's the only one who doesn't seem
like he's looking for a purpose right
whereas before it was all about honoring
his purpose
yeah he seems like he before coming in
contact with allison he just seemed kind
of content in like
accepting the fact that he stuck in this
time period yeah and kind of just like
embracing this new life one of my
favorite moments i thought was so
wonderfully weird in season one was the
dance scene
between luther and allison oh yeah it
was like very la la land yeah
yeah uh like the fantasy of like the
kind of romance he
he wished she could have had i guess
what makes the thing jarring about the
allison and luther thing and i actually
have no idea how
audiences feel about it one version of
it is they're kind of just a bunch of
kids who grew up in a school together
uh-huh
you know they're not aren't
blood-related does luther view everyone
else like brother and sister but
allison is the exception and he views
her
love interest you know like right how
does he framing his head
exactly and so that's where the line can
be kind of
weird when talking about the romance
with them
we've seen the kind of the uh the
sibling sort of thing with all the other
characters coming together with allison
and klaus and like with five and vania
and stuff but we don't really
know luther's kind of perspective review
as far as his interactions with his
other siblings
yeah he calls them brother and sister
but does he
view them as like everyone's brother and
sister except allison
i want to bang that one you know i
wonder if we're still going to get that
headbutting between uh diego and
luther yeah diego and luther this season
a lot more to unpack
it's interesting the focus of this
season because
you're like who's who's really the main
character this time
it's like five seems to be the center of
it five's the center of it but it
doesn't feel like anybody's getting the
short stick
no no this is great yeah yeah i mean but
we have head mass
uh uh handling handler headmaster
hammer you have handler just when the
show started getting me into the romance
between diego
and lily and then they pull that switch
so maybe from my prediction from last
episode maybe it won't be
handler who helps but maybe it'll be
lily who switches sides because yeah
what is the goal here why why what's
with the deep undercover stuff
yeah what's what's the objective why are
you guys trying to kill them from
stopping the apocalypse well that's what
they're trying to do in the first place
why diego specifically and why does she
have to go
inside the psych ward with him for all
this time yeah to break him out i was
like what
what's your deal what's what what what
deal with lily
i'm buying what you're selling girl all
right guys well what'd you think of this
episode anything we missed leave it down
in the comments below
subscribe click that notification bell
check us out on patreon for more goodies
last but not least
we have the best patron ejects today i'm
shouting out david gandy
so he sent a box my way for this stuff
right here
a whole rig for filming and stuff steady
cam yeah exactly
gimbal head wow that's exactly what it
is
i just forgot the name and i'm glad you
sought and knew it he sent us this and i
was like holy crap this thing is massive
and it's all nicely packaged
thank you david i knew you were gonna
send it our way but once i opened the
box i was like whoa there's
more stuff in this box that you did not
prepare me for oh damn hey i love this
bag too
all right so he said i hope you get some
good use out of it
greg check this out then i wore the aot
attack on timer hoodie only a few times
but never made my regular hoodie
rotation so i wash it up and we'll let
you
enjoy oh we're going to open up this box
i'm sorry
if i had known there was other stuff in
here i would have done a full unboxing i
found this
attack on titan hoodie oh cool wow
look at that that's right [ __ ]
that is crazy david dude this is my
first time putting it on oh look at you
ready to go fit ready to go fight the
titans
god there's something for you he says
john i like these acoustic strings a lot
hope you will too
[Music]
there you go thanks man ooh okay so we
got
he surprised the [ __ ] out of me dude
i am so surprised he was telling me
about
this gimbal and saying like yeah i don't
use it so you want them like of course
i'd love to have it then you're
surprised with this stuff
you rock dude thanks for making our day
i love you david i'm so surprised you're
the sweetest
when i opened the box and i saw the
attack on titan i'm like
this is david's box who said this i was
like what i wish i had known there were
other things that were also done a
proper unboxing but
you made doing your shout out even
easier thank you for all this dave
seriously